the third biggest footsie gainer was
Hammerson the company which owns
shopping centers including London's
Brent Cross Birmingham's boring and
Bristol's Cabot Circus so it's sharp
shares rise by fallen quarter percent
after adjusted full-year profits rose by
9% to who 231 million pounds although a
headline level they were down some fifty
six percent after the company cut the
valuation of his assets by 124 million
pounds david atkins is Hamilton's chief
executive and joins me now David the
striking thing about your results is
that your rental income rose by nine
percent and yet we've been hearing all
sorts of stories away from the retail
sector this year yeah well the earnings
grew by about nine percent that was
really driven by growth in income of
three-point-two percent in overall we
saw performance increasing across all of
our assets UK shopping centres retail
parks and particularly strong
performance from premium outlets this is
our luxury outlets of Europe 19 outlets
including bicester village they grew
seven point six percent so what we're
seeing though is still a very clear
focus of retailers who want to be in the
best locations like the assets we own
the really prime large assets and that's
driving rental income growth so you not
worried about the fact that we've just
had three consecutive months of drops in
retail sales across the board a lot of
data points and I think interestingly
most retailers would say that Christmas
was positive you know it wasn't a bad
Christmas I think post brexit there was
a little bit of reining in spending from
the consumer but overall consumer seems
to be in a pretty positive place
remember brexit more than half the
population voted for it so they're happy
and we're not seeing again that move
away from demand from retailers in our
schemes now you own five big French
shopping centres how has business been
over there full and all those terror
attacks half year but actually if you
look at the overall numbers consumer
spending in our centres was up three
percent really positive and valuations
grew about the same level so again
surprisingly perhaps for many people
here the French people showing their
recipients just as we have in past
terrorism entities and retailers again
very focused on where they want to be
driving good results from a valuation
and income point of view in four
ons for us now there's an awful lot of
anger in the retail set to run now about
the forthcoming business rates
revaluation has I can affect your
business well it's a tough one I mean I
think overall we feel that the rate
system needs reviewing it's an unjust
tax is outdated unfairly focused on
retail you know retail bears twenty-five
percent of the rates liability in the UK
but only amounts to five percent of
economic output clearly something has to
happen particularly as it unfairly
discriminates against bricks and mortar
retailers whilst online is growing and I
would say most people would agree that's
not taking its fair share of the burden
for us as a business because we're a
national UK retail business actually
it's a sort of zero-sum game what we use
if you like in London southeast we're
gaining with rates reductions elsewhere
so overall it's not not a negative
impact but particular reasons is being
it's being hard in a word David you've
got a couple of big developments on the
go Brent Cross and whitgift all gonna go
to time yet we're aiming very much to
get those on site next year a lot of key
milestones and really were into that
final straight of getting those schemes
on board